- Hi everyone. Good afternoon and welcome.
My name is Priya Natarajan.
I'm an astrophysicist with
strong intellectual interests
in the history and philosophy of science,
and I serve as the current director
of Yale's flagship
interdisciplinary Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities.
It's my absolute pleasure today
to start this wonderful event
by first recognizing our benefactors, Mr.
and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke.
Thanks to their generosity, this program
and many other initiatives
at Yale have benefited
from their vision to foster scholarship
that breaks disciplinary boundaries
and generates radical new lenses
to view the world through.
Meanwhile, before we start today's event,
I am required to give you this notice.
This event is being
recorded and photographed
for educational, archival
and promotional purposes,
including use in print on
the internet and other forms
of media.
By attending this event today, you agree
to the possibility of your
voice or your likeness captured
by these means and used for such purposes
without compensation to you
and hereby waive any related
right to privacy or publicity.
So before I introduce our
fantastic speaker this evening,
let me remind you that we
have reception upstairs
after the talk in the
student lounge immediately
after the event,
so you are all invited
to please come join us.
There's some really yummy food there.
So now onto today's event,
I can promise you it'll be a real treat.
This evening, we are
gathered for a book talk
by one of our own,
the incredible mind whom
we are fortunate to have
on our faculty at Yale,
professor Jing Tsu.
Professor Tsu, the John
M. Schiff Professor
of East Asian Languages and literatures
and Comparative Literature at
Yale is a cultural historian,
literary scholar of modern
China at Yale University.
The first tenured professor appointed
in East Asian languages and literatures
and comparative literature,
her research spans literature,
linguistics, science and
technology, internationalization,
regionalization, regionalism, sorry,
and globalization and US China relations.
She's a member and former chair
2014 to 2021 of the Council
on East Asian studies and
a senior research fellow
at the MacMillan Center for
International and Area Studies
and an affiliate faculty
at the Jackson School of Global Affairs.
Professor Tsu has written
for The New York Times,
New York Times Book Review,
The Financial Times,
and has authored or co-edited five books.
Her most recent book which is
what we're gonna be hearing
about today, "Kingdom of
Characters: The Language Revolution
That Made China Modern" was named
among the hundred notable books of 2022
by The New York Times and the
best non-fiction of 2022 list
in The Washington Post.
It's been reviewed extensively.
Pretty much every major
publication has reviewed it
across the world, including
The New York Times,
The Wall Street Journal,
Financial Times, The New Yorker,
Economist, Wired, Science, Nature,
The Guardian, Times Literary Supplement,
London Review of Books,
and the South China Morning
Post, and of course the NRC
in Holland and the Frankfurter
Allemand in Germany.
This book tells the story of how China
and its language entered the
information age dominated
by the Western alphabet.
In spring 2023,
Jing Tsu is delivering Yale's
William Clyde DeVane lectures,
"China in Six Keys."
Jing is widely recognized
for her original approach,
interdisciplinary synthesis
and perspective on China.
She has held fellowships
and honors from a multitude
of places, including the
Society of Fellows at Harvard,
the Woodrow Wilson Foundation,
the Center for Advanced Study
in the Behavioral Sciences
at Stanford, the Alexander
von Humboldt Foundation,
the Radcliffe Institute,
New Directions Fellowship
from the Mellon Foundation,
and the Institute for Advanced Study
and the John Simon Guggenheim Foundation.
I don't need to tell you this.
She's an extremely distinguished scholar,
whose work we are really
excited to hear more about.
Before we start the event and
I invite Jing to the stage,
I want to mention a couple
of our ongoing projects
and upcoming events.
So we have a learning by doing project,
which is we are collecting
little simple science videos
of little experiments that can
be done at home for children
around the world who can
do little experiments just
to fulfill their curiosity.
So if you would like to
be a contributor and send
in a video, please go ahead
and take a look at our website.
We would be delighted.
The next announcement I want to make,
quick one is next Wednesday at 4:00 PM,
we have a film screening of
"The Lost Leonardo" followed
by a full post film moderated discussion
with Dianne Modestini,
the famed art conservator,
whose restoration work
actually led to the discovery
of the artwork and was
critical in establishing
that it was a Leonardo.
So yeah, please mark your calendars,
next Wednesday at 4:00 PM.
And on Tuesday April 18th,
we have another wonderful book talk
by one of our own, professor Beverly Gage,
who will be talking to
us about her recent book,
"G-Man: J. Edgar Hoover and the Making
of the American Century."
And on April 26th we have,
"We Carry Our World Within
Us: Cellular Structures
That Allow Us To Live in A
Very Hostile Environment."
I want to often read out these 'cause
to show you how interdisciplinary
the offerings are.
So please mark your
calendars and I look forward
to seeing you at many of these events.
So, it's a particular pleasure
for me as Jing also happens
to be a close friend
so without further ado,
Jing, the floor is yours.
Thank you so much for coming.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you very much, Priya.
I have to first thank the Franke program
for having me today.
I'm not sure if any talk
I can deliver can live up
to the very generous
introduction from Priya.
But as you know, we're friends. (chuckles)
In any case, it's a delight to be here.
I feel that it's long overdue
since the book came out a year ago
and I thank also Ellis Kaplan,
director of the humanities
center last year,
Whitney Humanities Center,
who invited me to come speak.
So today, as I've given a
lot of talks on this book,
I thought I'd share with you here
in some ways the path that led me to it.
That's why it's called
"Behind Kingdom Characters"
in some ways, and I'll take you
through this particular
thread in the book.
There's really three points of genesis
and one actually brings
me back to my roots
as a literary scholar.
As a student of monetized literature,
any student will have
read all the writings,
if not most by this man, Hu Shi.
He was a proponent of
using vernacular speech
to replace on the elite
literary classical Chinese
in the early 20th century.
This was a movement
that really revolutionized modern China
because it gave language
back to the people,
the power of literacy
and this is really the beginning of it.
But of all the things that
you will read by Hu Shi,
there's this one here
that's often unnoticed
and it took me years until
I embarked in this book
to realize that all the evidence
and the cues were there.
I just didn't quite see it
when I was strictly a
student of literature.
So this is a preface that he wrote
to this scheme on Chinese characters,
which I will talk about in a bit.
He talks about, of all
things, not vernacular
versus elite language, but
the idea of organization.
And he says here,
"To order is to find a
logical threat in chaos."
And here, he's actually
commenting on this immense task
that Chinese were faced with
in the early 20th century.
How do they actually preserve and hold on
to the written heritage, given
that there's an onslaught
of Westernization and
a pressure monetization
that was basically making
old knowledge seem old
and unpopular and very kind of calcified?
But then when he talks
about this, he said,
"You know, what's really important,
the hard task is really
this very pedestrian,
very mundane thing to do
which is to make sure
that you can find things
where you find them."
And that is tedious for sure
and he talks about how this is really kind
of like a service industry part
of modern Chinese literature,
that there's gonna be people
who will have to do it
and they will be like
the saviors and martyrs
for literature, but of
course not Hu Shi himself,
although he will support them.
And he said,
"People who engage in this
kind of painstaking labor do it
so that other people don't have to."
And so regardless, oh sorry.
I'm not sure why this just fell out.
Is it coming up? Great. Sorry.
Now you see what I'm
reading from. (laughs)
Sorry for the momentary blindness.
So regardless of what people do,
the scholarly world is
utterly indebted to them.
So it's this group of people
that I got very interested in.
Who is this invisible community
that managed to carry
modern Chinese literature,
the very language that made
up literature, on their backs,
but who went utterly unrecognized?
And you know, as Hu Shi said,
they're basically doomed to anonymity.
So that was my first thread
right there, my first clue,
and I tucked this away in my mind.
And about 10 years ago when I
was working into the history
of science and technology,
I decided to educate myself
by reading these very famous seminal works
by Joseph Needham called,
"Science and Civilization in China."
It was about 26 volumes.
Don't worry, I didn't
get through all of 'em.
26 volumes and Joseph Needham
was a towering figure.
And in 1956, in volume two,
he made these references
in footnotes about the Chinese language.
And you can see that this
is where this towering mind
at the time,
he had doubts about the
fundamental task he was undertaking
which was to justify
and explain how China had always
had science and technology,
right, to refute the fact that just
because that scientific
revolution took place
in the West, does it mean
that China didn't have
their own accomplishments,
scientific and technological?
But he had a doubt when
it came to the language.
And he will quote other people
in these footnotes and say,
"Well, some people say that it's something
about the Chinese language
that hampers through thinking, right,
that kind of skews the
way or limits the way
or charts a particular
way of thinking because
of the character idiographic
writing system they had."
But clearly, he had doubts
because he did not put that
in a main body
and there was yet another
footnote that says,
"Well, Chinese seem
particularly well-positioned
to think comminatory logic
by virtue of the fact
that character writing
are made of parts rather
than alphabetic letters
in a linear rollout."
So that was my second clue and
I kinda wondered about that.
Is it true at the time?
Is it true that alphabetical thinking,
the alphabetic mind in
some ways was more amenable
to modernization?
Was it more superior?
Was it more accessible?
Was it easier than idiographic thinking
or thinking in the Chinese
character language?
And of course, when I
looked into the literature
and the scholarship, the
history that have been written
in my field, it wasn't very
helpful because whenever we talk
about Chinese language,
it was very much cast in a frame of, ah,
superiority versus inferiority,
the inferiorization of
Chinese language and culture
and the way that we put them as primitive
or more backwards as opposed
to Western civilization, right?
Which is actually a
relatively recent hierarchy
that happened in the 19th
century with the revolution.
And so I looked in other places,
hoping that there were other disciplines
that could give me a clue.
And this is around 2015 where
I then came across a subfield
in neuroscience, which was a study,
the neuroscience of reading.
So writing system, you know,
we might not think about
this, is actually very young.
It basically developed
within a blink of an eye
in the larger shape of evolution, right?
About 5,000 years, 5,500 years old.
So, it's not really possible
that evolutionarily,
we could have adapted,
our brains could've adapted so quickly
that we have a particular set of neurons
that just deal with writing.
So it turns out they're built
on a prior infrastructure
of pattern recognition,
of identifying, you know,
where the horizon meets,
where there's intersection in the roads.
You will also know that when you look out
at the expanse of the ocean, you know,
you normally fix your
gaze somewhere, right?
So that's what we're kind of fine-tuned
for evolutionary purposes so
that we can find our way home
after we, you know, hit
that tiger over the head
or deer or try to carry
it back to our caves.
So it makes a lot of sense.
And it took me to Marina Delray
to visit a neuroscientist
who were the first
to talk about pattern recognition
and the visual image
processing, Irving Biederman,
whom actually, I was sad to
find out just the other day
that he passed away in 2022.
And so, this train of thought
then led me down another rabbit hole
because it turns out
according to neuroscientists,
there are different ways
and different startup costs
for reading the alphabet or
reading autographic writing,
but eventually it all comes out
pretty much the same, right?
Literacy in literacy, we learn to accustom
and to connect patterns in such a way
that they become conventionalized
and internalized,
and that's when we read them.
So, this is kinda the bottom line,
but I'm still not quite satisfied.
So, what is it about the Chinese language
that's so mystified for centuries
that baffled the Western
missionaries since the 16th century
that have given rise to
accusations and assumptions
of inferiority, of what
held the Chinese back
in the 20th century, so on and so forth?
And the criticism was not just coming
from Westerners themselves,
but also the Chinese.
They too came to see, mainly
because their interaction
with the Western alphabet, how cumbersome,
in some ways how unfriendly
the Chinese language was
to modernity.
So it was my goal, then, to set out
to prove or to figure
out, is that really true
and if so, why.
And there's also a more
direct route to this
because when I was working
on my last book in 2010,
"Sound and Script in Chinese Diaspora",
one of my favorite writers,
Lin Yutang, turned out,
his lifelong passion was to
build a Chinese typewriter.
At the time, I didn't
know what to make of this
and quite disappointed, of course.
As a student of literature,
you imagine these writers
just locked themselves away
in an attic and to, you know,
listen to their muse and write away
but he had a very mechanical
engineer-like mind.
And so, I flagged it
in this chapter called,
"Lin Yutang's Typewriter" and I vowed
that I would come back to it,
and so hence about a decade later,
after going through many other,
I think digressions and detours and many,
many archives and delving
deep into this and talking
to many people in the industry
'cause that's what this project took
and that's where we are now.
So, let me just go back to this.
You will see that the
footnote is from an article
that Hu Shi wrote.
I mentioned that's a preface.
It's a preface
to something called the
"Four Corner Index System."
And it's by a man, Wang
Yunwu, who was not alone
in this endeavor.
So what this meant was,
(indistinct) organization,
just as in the alphabet,
you see in dictionaries,
this all organized by ABCD,
you might not appreciate
the power of the alphabet.
But this incredible ease and efficiency
of self-organization has meant a lot
of different other kinds
of conveniences, right?
You know, B never comes before
A, you know, T comes after S.
So this predictability
gives an immense power
in simply organizing libraries.
You can look up anything
in the dictionary,
anything to catalog, telephone directories
and even early days of computing.
So, the fact that you just
need to learn 26 symbols
and then you can construct
any word you want
in the English language, in
all Indo-European languages,
out of those 26 symbols,
it's actually remarkable.
Now, if I can shift you to
look at Chinese characters,
there's about 80,000,
depending on who you ask.
Of course, not all of 'em are
being used at any given time.
And in fact for modern day literacy,
you probably need three, four,
three to 5,000 characters.
Still a lot compared to 26.
I can tell you stories of, you know,
one of the strongest memories, growing up,
is writing these characters
over and over again.
You would get anywhere between
15 to 35, 40 of them a day
in school and the bulk of your homework,
at least back in the 80s,
would be to just repeat
them over and over again
to commit them to muscle memory.
So, what this man did in
"Four Corner Index System" was
to figure out how to use characters
to give them this kind
of indexical function.
And what he proposed was, actually,
lemme just skip here a
little bit, about here is,
to put it very simply there,
he basically takes parts of characters
'cause you see that Chinese characters are
in a square space.
So roughly, he can divide
it up into four quadrants.
And you can use the corner,
if you identify the contour of
what the character looks like
in the corner, you assign a number to it.
So his idea is that, okay,
there were four numbers.
You can tag a character on all four sides
and that will help you zoom in
and hone in on the character
that you're looking for.
Now this is very
important because why else
and how else would you look for characters
to fish 'em out of, let's say,
80 thousands or thousands?
So he was not alone in this.
There was Chen Guanyao, who
wrote the "Standard Radicals",
"Simplified Characters Index."
There was Shen Zurong and Hu Qingsheng's,
"Look-Up in 12 Character Strokes."
So this is from 1920s and 1940s.
There was a massive, massive race
to find what's called a
character retrieval system,
the golden key that will
unlock all these doors,
and the list goes on and on.
Now, Wang Yunwu was the one
that's highlighted in red,
but he was not the only one,
although the most successful.
In fact, one of the pleasures
of working on this book is
to basically engage with
these human characters
behind every Chinese character
that made their preservation possible.
And when you get to know
them, you understand why.
For instance, this man, Zhang Feng,
a young man at the time, had the audacity
of perhaps having hope of
challenging Wang Yunwu's system.
Now, Wang Yunwu
at the time was already
a publishing maverick.
He was very well connected.
He claims to have been an autodidact,
taught himself by reading
"Encyclopedia Britannica"
from page to page.
He got up at four every morning,
drank gallons of water and
go on like a brisk walk.
It was to create allure around himself,
so obviously he was also
a marketing maverick.
Now Zhang Feng was this young man,
who obviously was very smart
and he had a great idea
about tagging characters, not by numbers,
but by looking at its shape
and he organized a kind of
simpler system this way.
And so, he was all but
20 something years old
and decided he wants to
challenge Wang Yunwu.
And he made the mistake,
one could say in retrospect,
by issuing a public
challenge in a newspaper,
asking him to almost like a duel.
I have no idea what that would've
looked like in real life.
I dunno if he'd throw
characters at each other
or pieces of paper at each other.
Then in the case, he issued
that challenge and he did a lot.
He carried his samples,
he gave them to anyone
he could teach it to.
He really tried to publicize,
but it was only one man, right?
And he could not possibly
defeat the entire,
publicity machinery that Wang
Yunwu had at his fingertips
because he did something very clever,
which was at the time,
he was a main editor
for the biggest publishing house
in China, Commercial Press,
which still exists today.
And Commercial Press put out
all these reference works,
which was actually not
common prior to 20th century,
but modern reference works
like the dictionary, thesaurus,
et cetera, et cetera.
And to use any of them,
you had to learn Wang
Yunwu's four corner system.
I can tell you,
the four corner system is
not easy to use (laughs)
and yet, it still persisted
when I was in graduate school
at Harvard in 2000s where
that's still how you have
to look up certain things
in the old catalog system.
So Wang Yunwu was quite successful.
He basically did the one thing I think
that would bruise any young ego.
He just simply ignored Zhang Feng.
And Zhang Feng pretty
much fell into anonymity,
but his scheme is actually
one that won a lot of,
I think, confirmation much later on.
So what's really at stake
when we talk about characters?
Well, there's also the
added external perception
of Chinese characters
that didn't really help,
didn't really help highlight
this intrinsically materialist,
technological challenge that
posed for the modern age
because since to 17, actually
16, but more famously,
17th century, Europeans
have been fantasizing
and imagining what Chinese
writing was all about, right,
the exotic character.
Here, this is a man,
Athanasius Kircher who's very well known.
He wrote this book, "China Illustrata",
which was published in
1667 where he shows, right,
that characters written
this fair ornate way,
they're so in tune in nature
that they're literally put
together by turtles or bugs,
if you can see that, if
you can see that below.
And most Europeans who actually
had not traveled abroad,
did this just go out?
Is this still on? Okay.
Most Europeans who
actually had not traveled
abroad took his word for it and he
in turn took other people's word for it
because there were
missionaries who went to China
and actually tried to work
with the Chinese language
on the ground,
but Kircher had a particular
imagination about what it was.
And this kind of imagination or fantasy
about the Chinese language
will persist down to our day.
But I just wanna point
out how powerful it was
that external perception had
begun this other kind of lore
about the Chinese language.
And I also wanna say as a
footnote that it turns out,
it was not completely
Kircher's imagination.
He didn't just pull this out
of a hat because at the time,
there were certain books
that were translated,
or actually brought back to Europe,
putting libraries, et cetera.
And one of those books
that we are quite sure he
saw was this particular one
which was known as a
popular almanac at the time.
It's hard to describe what it is,
but it's sort of a for
layman, popular usage,
and it was to sort of decorate
and kinda exaggerate sort
of Chinese character writing
for decorative purposes largely.
And then so, any Chinese
wouldn't take this seriously
as high knowledge.
But of course for Europeans
who were just kind
of bringing these books back,
they didn't really have
the context to evaluate.
So what Kircher turned out,
where he got it from was simply
this very popular almanac
that is not really part of
the Chinese language theory.
Believe that as it may,
this imagination persisted.
How do you deal with these thousands,
tens of thousands of characters?
Well, in 1897, the first
person would try to put Chinese
into a typewriter, was this Presbyterian,
American Presbyterian missionary.
So I wanna extend with the fact
that this Chinese language,
the technologization of Chinese language,
was not just a Chinese affair.
It's not just the Chinese
who were concerned about it.
Outsiders, foreigners,
Westerners were equally concerned
because they want a way
to break into China,
into its market to win the
hearts and minds of its peoples,
to proselytize, to convert
them, et cetera, et cetera.
So, Sheffield's answer was,
well, kind of workmanlike.
He decides,
"Well, of course you need
to basically have a key
for every character and you have a place
with every whole character."
So he put thousands on
what is basically like,
a flat disk drum, and
you find the character.
So all the little dots that you see
on it are actually
supposed to be characters.
And then you sort of crank that,
use that crane and you somehow
line it up with the needle
on top and then do this very laborious,
it's basically like a
three, four step process,
but you can imagine a
person who's doing it,
it's almost like rubbing your
tummy and patting your head
at the same time because you
have to rotate on one hand,
but then also kind of push
and pull with the other.
They were very physically challenging,
but Sheffield kinda meant it that way.
He said,
"Because, you know,
the physical labor will
teach those lazy people how
to actually remember, learn characters."
He's talking about his
fellow missionaries, right?
That they actually have
to commit characters
to memory the same way that Chinese do.
But nonetheless, it was not
a very imaginative solution
because this was obviously cumbersome,
difficult to use even though
it seemed like a giant leap
forward at the time,
because this is what we're dealing with.
Now, this is a keyboard
tray. It's inverted, right?
So you see the characters
in this sort of mirror image
and each of those characters are carved
into these lead slugs.
And every time you want
to print something,
you would take out a tray,
you arrange these characters
just like the way you have it
in the text and then you
use it to print that way.
And China actually
invented this technology
in the 11th century, the movable type.
At the time, it was kind of
made of clay, not quite lead.
But this technology of literally,
you have to carve each character
into a slug and then use it
to type and rearrange it for a text
and then do it all over again
to fish 'em out, you know,
of a storage and then do it
like over and over again,
this was actually a main technique
for printing up to mid 20th century.
Pretty remarkable.
Was it cumbersome for Chinese? Yes.
But they also found a way
around this such that,
if you can believe it,
it was faster for them
to melt down everything
at the end of the day and
then recast the next day
than it is for them to try
to locate these characters, right?
So the main issue really is,
and who should had absolutely
right, how to select,
retrieve and locate characters.
That was gonna be key to almost
everything in modernization
because if you don't
modernize your language,
nothing else will be able to.
So, that previous image of the type,
the tray of types is actually
a closeup of this typewriter.
There's three of them in the
United States, three existing.
This one is in the
Museum of Chinese America
in New York City.
Another one's in the
Huntington Library in Pasadena,
and the third one we believe
is in private collection.
So this is called a Shu-style,
this Chinese typewriter,
because this man Shu actually
did not invent it himself,
but he built it based on the model
by a previous Chinese typewriter inventor.
After Sheffield in 1897,
it was this young man, Zhou Houkun,
who actually went to MIT.
He's actually a second class,
but one of the first wave of
Chinese students who were sent
abroad to study MIT, Cornell,
et cetera, et cetera.
And he was a double major.
He was actually the first
graduate aeronautical engineering,
which was a brand new
program MIT at the time,
present day avionics.
And this was also not supposed
to be his senior thesis.
His senior thesis was
about how to make a bamboo
as strong as concrete.
But, as with my writer, Lin Yutang,
this was his passion and he worked
on this whenever he was not
working on his homework.
So the Shu-style Chinese
typewriter works with,
you see that there's a
tray of slugs, right?
And every time you moved
this, there's no keyboard.
That's the important
thing to bear in mind.
There's a forest of keys, but no keyboard.
So you can't really type it.
You can only kind of locate it
through kinda like Sheffield's typewriter,
which Zhou Houkun actually
took a lot of inspiration from.
Zhou Houkun recognized
that each character would
still have his own slug,
its own type, that characters
cannot be divided up.
Because he inherited this
thinking, and this is true,
Chinese characters, traditionally,
there's only one part of
it that can be singled out
for indexical purposes,
but it doesn't quite fit
the purpose of modern needs.
So this is Zhou Houkun, the MIT student,
and his solution to a force
of keys was basically,
he only had a blueprint.
We know that he built a
typewriter, but he was a star MIT.
He had job offers in the United States,
but he decided that he
would go back to China
because he had thought,
"Airplanes is not what China needed now
where there's not even cars,
but if you could bring back a way
of printing Chinese characters,
of mechanizing the Chinese language so
that you can make print
and literacy accessible,
that would be the one
measure that will be critical
to China's national survival."
So my favorite story
about this is actually,
Zhou Houkun comes back.
He goes back to Shanghai where he's from
and he gives his very dramatic lecture.
It was a very hot summer night in Shanghai
and they were so hot, they
were serving ice cream
to attract more crowd.
And Zhou Houkun showed up,
he had this perfectly
coiffed hair, Western suit.
I don't think he was a terribly funny man
from the way he looks.
Pretty serious fellow,
and he had with him a
briefcase and he carried it up
to the podium with him,
kinda like where I am.
He puts it next to his feet.
And just as everyone quieted down,
he did this very odd thing.
He opened up the briefcase
and took out what looked
like workman's overalls
and he pulled it over
his suit and he said,
"Don't be afraid to get your hands dirty."
And what did he mean by that?
Because traditionally,
manual labor was looked down
upon in China.
There's a reason why it's a
society or civilization built
on literacy and learnedness
and prized learning as such.
So anyone who worked with a
manual labor like craftsmen
or carpentry, it was really
kinda like secondary.
It was more like a skill, right?
It was not knowledge.
It's more like skill.
But Zhou Houkun, having gone
through an engineering program
in the United States, having
actually interned in factories,
knew that was not the case.
And to modernize,
China had to strengthen
engineering mechanics
as scientific learning.
And to do that, he believed
you had to correct a prejudice
against the kind of
modernity and modernization.
So it was a very successful night.
Unfortunately, his efforts
didn't go very far.
He actually got a job at
Commercial Press, Commercial Press,
the same press we were talking about,
except he couldn't
really quite pull it off.
The parts that he required
for the typewriter was too expensive
and he was so accustomed to
the conditions at MIT and,
you know, in the United
States that he was appalled
by the degree of, you
know, workmanship, right,
precision workmanship.
He was very frustrated and decided,
he would tell Commercial Press like,
"Why don't you gimme money to send me back
to the United States and
let me do this there?"
And the editor at the time,
who is this classic Confucian
scholar, very, very shrewd,
he's like,
"No, no, no, we're not putting money back
in America's pockets.
You have to do that here."
But he said,
"You know what, why don't you just go?
You know, you'd be free of our contract,
free fine contract."
And it's very clever because
what Commercial Press did was,
they kept the prototype
and they kept the blueprint
of this typewriter.
So Zhou Houkun actually
ended up doing fine.
You don't have to worry
too much about him,
but he didn't do much with his typewriter.
But then Commercial Press decided,
"You know, these Ivy League returnings."
(Jing laughing)
"These Ivy League registered
educator returnees,
they come back and they're
spoiled and, you know,
they expect this and that.
We need someone hungrier."
So he found this man, Shu,
a young man who didn't get to
go to America for education
and he came back and he basically
produced this typewriter.
But still, that did not
quite solve all the problems
because you're still talking
about whole characters.
So we're not exactly using
characters like alphabet, right?
You still can't break it
down like the way you can,
a word into letters.
So you still have to deal
with the sheer challenge
of number and size.
So amidst all these people,
all these inventors and you
know, mavericks and eccentrics,
because there were many
eccentrics in this race,
there was another one that came
to rise above everyone else.
That is, I'm happy to say,
my writer, Lin Yutang.
Already, we see a man who I think is born
to be well bred and well liked.
And he was actually a famous
humorist. He wrote essays.
He became, actually, the most
beloved and probably still
to date the most well known
Chinese writer in America.
He was here in the 30s and 40s.
So Lin Yutang came up
with the idea of a clear
and quick typewriter.
And why is it clear and quick?
He went back and looked
at the Chinese character
and realized that, remember,
I told you just a few minutes
ago that Chinese characters,
you can use one part,
it's actually called
the classifier radical
to identify into group characters.
He had this idea,
"Well, why can't you treat
all parts of a character as
though it were radical?"
So you basically break down
each character into parts
or what he called components,
what came to be known as components.
And once you have these
components, you can lay them out,
map 'em onto an alphabetic
keyboard, right,
like the QWERTY keyboard we still use,
and then you can use that
as a way of combining
and recombining characters.
So this is actually quite
brilliant because of that turn,
that shift in mentality, right?
Lin Yutang managed to basically
map Chinese characters
onto this keyboard.
And what you have is, I think
the top two rows, top two,
three rows has the top components.
He had this idea.
Even if you don't know characters at all,
if you look at like a character,
surely you can tell what's
on top and what's on bottom.
That's actually all you need
because he broke out these
parts into top and bottoms
on the keyboard
so that you select a top
key, you select a bottom key,
you press both keys together.
Okay, it's still a few more
steps, but bear with me.
But then you have this,
what's called a magic viewer.
It's like a little window,
a physical window that pops up and just
through his statistical analysis,
it will give you anywhere
between five to eight Chinese
characters that fit the bill.
And then you visually identify
which one of those five
or eight is the character you have in mind
and then you press a key,
which is actually where
the current space bar is
where you have your keyboard space bar,
he divided that up into eight keys,
number one through eight.
So you just press the corresponding key.
So in three steps, you can
put the character you want
on a piece of paper.
It's actually quite
extraordinary 'cause also,
this is still mechanical age.
This is like, far before electronic,
let alone mechanical or let alone digital.
So this was all done with levers and poles
and maximizing what's
inside the wheels and axles.
It was pretty extraordinary,
and this is what that keyboard looks like.
This is actually from
the patent application
that he submitted in the
late 1940s that was approved,
I believe, in 1952.
Now, he gives demonstrations.
Again, you can see he's very
camera friendly, actually.
And that's his daughter, by the way,
who will go to do these demos with him.
And essentially, he
said the magic viewers,
the one that you see works
or opens out to the window,
it's kinda this cumbersome thing
but if any of you that might
use Chinese characters,
when you type, you will
also notice that these days,
when you type in what you want,
if you spell out the Chinese character,
you also get a window, right?
You still can't just fish
out the exact one you want.
You get a window of the likely candidates
and you basically have to like,
scroll through, scroll
through, scroll through.
That repeatedly comes from
Lin Yutang's invention.
But there's an even bigger deal with this,
a kind of backstory and
this is how, you know,
these different histories
have a way of connecting
and getting forgotten and
then remembered again.
Now, Lin Yutang also had
a similar disappointment
with his typewriter because of
the problem of mass scaling.
So that's been the bottleneck all along.
You can create a great prototype,
but this comes to, okay,
like, how do we build thousands, hundreds,
not just one or two.
And he couldn't find
factories that could do this
and the parts, because they
all had to be customized,
was very expensive.
So he eventually sold it
to the Mergenthaler Linotype company
and they gave him 25,000
dollars for it, okay?
But this was also the 50s.
This was the era of
Cold War, cryptography,
where machine translation,
where the United States
and the Americans, Russians
were trying to break into
and intercept each other's messages or,
you know, using machine
to translate, you know,
automatic translation.
And the Chinese language figured
a prominent role in this.
So Mergenthaler handed it over
to actually the United States
Air Force who then handed it
over to IBM for further development.
In the summer of 1967, I believe,
I'll have to check that, maybe it was 63,
IBM unveiled something
called the sinal writer.
It had a couple of different names,
but the sinal writer basically
used Lin Yutang's keyboard,
the one you just saw,
this one to create basically
a prototype that will lead
to later, Chinese computing
in the United States.
Now, this was not the only path
because there was also a
project at MIT at the time
with this graphic arts
research foundation, GARF,
based in Cambridge that was also trying
to build kind of first
Chinese computer, so to speak.
But they too, this man Samuel
Caldwell, who people thought,
you know, I think he's
been called the father
of Chinese computing.
He was an American. He
didn't know Chinese.
And what's also not very well known is
that he also relied on Lin
Yutang's character analysis
because when he was
first called in to talk
about the project, I think
there was three people
in the room.
There was him, his boss,
a third person who was a
Chinese graduate student, PhD,
who came to work with Caldwell.
And he was handed a task
of doing a first survey
into the feasibility of
doing something like this
and he basically provided all
the Chinese language know-how
to Caldwell.
So, one of the reasons
I really like about,
this is one of the many
stories that interweave
through "Kingdom of Characters",
is really how something
so niche and so esoteric
and so overlooked could
play such a big role
into the globalization and the possibility
of China's presence in the world now.
Because getting Chinese
into computing was the door
that would open all other doors.
And even during cultural revolution,
the state very much
recognized that and they had
to grit their teeth through obviously,
I think, the extreme conditions
of culture revolution
but even throughout
the culture revolution,
there was always
individuals like Lin Yutang,
like Zhou Houkun who
kept that threat going.
And to me, the Chinese Script Revolution,
was the true people's revolution, right?
And it's the longest, most forgotten,
and it's not the people
as in what is invoked
by the Chinese government.
It is not the people invoked
by the nationalist government
before that.
It's really people from all walks of life,
you know, the second,
third stringers of history, I like to say,
who are neither radical
nor really revolutionary,
but they were the ones
who picked up the pieces
after every war, after every invasion,
and to think about they're
the ones who cared and think
about what China is
gonna be in the future.
So I leave that story here and
I'll welcome any questions.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you so much, Jing,
for that absolutely fascinating talk.
We have a microphone that is moving.
(microphone moving)
For the young volunteer who relishes.
- Oh my goodness.
(people laughing)
- What do I do?
(everyone laughing)
- Just talk.
- Is that, oh, good.
(everyone laughing)
So I just wanna clarify,
is Lin Yutang derived radicals
or recognized radical?
He was the first person
to recognize radicals?
- He did it in a particular
way in an essay in 1917.
So he was a young man.
No one really knew exactly
who he was, really.
He wrote these two very
un-sexy essays for the time
'cause everybody's talking
about revolution and, you know,
vernacularization and
overthrowing this and that.
He wrote a very modest piece
about library catalogs,
library index system.
And then after that,
he actually was not part of
this race in the 20s and 30s
because then, he went abroad.
He went and got his PhD
in Leipzig, Germany.
He went to Harvard, he became a writer.
But that opening salvo,
everybody else heard it.
And so, a lot of the inventors
in the book were the ones
that kind of followed his footsteps,
but then did something new with it.
- Hmm. Hm, thank you.
Can I throw this?
- I think that's what I'm worried about.
- I think you just toss it. (laughs)
- Okay, next question?
I'm gonna toss it. Shall I toss it?
- Oh my goodness. (laughs)
- Yes. Okay.
So, all of that took place
before simplified characters?
- I'm so glad you asked that.
You know, we think of simplified writing,
simplified characters and
also romanization pinging
as the twin achievements
under Mao in the 50s.
But you'd be surprised to know
that simplified characters
were proposed way before them
by the nationalists in as early as 1909.
And in the 30s,
the nationalists were
the ones who proposed,
while they were the
reigning government then,
they proposed a set of
characters to be simplified,
but they couldn't push it
through for two reasons.
China was in the throes of war, right?
Throughout the 20th century,
it was just torn by internal
like, civil war, war lordism,
revolution, foreign invasion,
one after the other.
And the other reason is
because they met resistance.
There were these, you know,
older members of the party who actually,
a very dramatic description of
one scene where one got down
on his knees to tell him,
"Leave the Chinese characters alone!"
You know, for them, I mean,
part of it is a difficulty
in shifting frame of mind,
like a way of thinking
and they're just saying
you cannot touch anything
on the character, like the idea,
the idea of deforming
Chinese writing system,
which is obnoxious to
many and unacceptable
and also because historically,
Chinese writing has always
been equated with authority.
There's very few writing systems
that comes with such a rich
and kind of imposing philosophical
theory about, you know,
its origin and what it meant.
- Thank you.
Pass? (chuckles) All right.
- [Attendant] Thanks so much.
I guess my question is building off that.
Why the 20th century?
Like, you talk a lot
about like, Hu Shi, right?
And like, obviously a lot of
early 20th century thinkers
and like, their drive to kind
of categorize and like, look
into library science
and there's this like,
focus on the character
and breaking it down.
And, you know, what I feel
like a lot of people end
up learning in Chinese class is like, oh,
one of the big like,
inventions of the first emperor
of China is this character system
to unify all these ethnic
groups and diverse cultures.
So I'm kind of curious on
why this drive to like,
in this hyper focus on library
science and categorization
in the early 20th century
rather than like, earlier.
- Well this is why this is
the main argument of the book,
which is because what we saw was,
when language became infrastructure.
Today I gave a story
about Chinese typewriting
and Lin Yutang because he's a writer
and I'm a literature person,
but a big part of the book's also
about telegraphs and telegraphy.
How do you expect to send
a telegram in Chinese
if you're using Morse code,
which is dots and dashes for letters
and actually numbers too, but
letters not character writing?
So far in 1870s,
China went through this
extraordinary period
of trying to figure
out how to enter itself
into an air of telegraphy
and at that time,
it couldn't take control of its fate
because there was all this competition
between actually the Danes
and the British to break it.
They had the big telegraphic
companies, an interest
in breaking into the far East.
And so the Danes, there's
this very famous episode,
one moonless night I talk about this
where they basically
secretly snuck onto cables
onto Chinese territory and just built it,
despite the Chinese having said,
"No, don't do it."
And there's a lot of popular revolt, too,
against foreigners building
telegraphs because of course,
some of these cables go underground.
And of course for Chinese,
this is blasphemous
because they were digging
through ancestral graves and
the idea that you would disturb
and basically, you know,
defame your ancestors
that way was just utterly unacceptable.
So there were popular
revolts on countryside
against foreign intrusion
so telegraphy became a
part of foreign intrusion.
But all this really is to say it started,
we can trace this to opium war, right?
That forced China to try to figure
out what its standing
was, vis-a-vis the West.
But more importantly, you know,
telegraphy, typewriting, computing,
these were all critical
bottlenecks in the history
of what's become the most
important thing of our day,
which is global communications technology.
So China, at each step of the way,
it was trying to break into
this infrastructure, right?
But it had to mold itself
to an alphabetic structure
because the Western alphabet
had the first mover advantage.
And in the history of
technology, you know,
technology and science,
you all learn very quickly
that it's almost impossible
to break a first mover's advantage
because a class example was QWERTY.
I mean I think most people
know about the QWERTY keyboard,
where it comes from.
Why is it, you know, it's
ordered that, with the letters
that are put next to each other?
So to prevent hammers from sticking,
we use these really old style typewriters,
which I remember my grandmother
had when I was a kid.
So, you know, that's
completely useless now.
They're using computers.
We don't use those clunky typewriters
and we haven't in a long time,
but that habit is ingrained.
So even though other more
accessible and, you know,
better keyboards came
along the Dvorak thing,
it didn't really matter
because people were habituated.
So you can imagine how after
thousands and thousands
of years of using a
particular writing system
and to shift to figure
out, how do we communicate,
resistance to communicate
with the alphabet,
it took extraordinary determination,
but also I think change,
the willingness to change,
which was very, very difficult
for China to do, right?
If you imagine an empire on its last legs
in late 19th century, all of a sudden,
it's this brave new world.
They had learned something
called technology.
That's why they were
just sending students,
like Zhou Houkun abroad
'cause they didn't have
the technical know-how.
So that's what unleashed all this.
So we think, I mean,
little did I know that when
I started this project,
that library of science would
be the one thing I spent a lot
of time with or that my favorite character
in the book is actually the librarian
in chapter four who called
himself Bismarck Deux
because he wanted to rule
the field of library science
with an iron fist. (laughs)
So there's, you know, these
extraordinary stories,
I think in the individuals
'cause it's not often the state,
that the Chinese nation who's competing.
It's wasn't like that.
China was in such disarray, you know,
throughout the 20th century.
So much loss of lives,
so much displacement.
That's why it's all the
more remarkable that
in those dark times, and
there's some very dark times,
what inspired my innovators
and these individuals is precisely that.
The light at the end of the tunnel,
it was something they could hold onto,
something they could save, right?
Something they possessed
because it was language
and they felt that if
they do what they could,
they may help one day to
contribute to China's rise.
- [Priya] I think as you note,
right, it's very interesting
that library science is really
how Google got its start.
Their first proposal to NSF
was a library classification
and the search engine
really came out of that.
- Yeah.
- So it's kind of interesting
how all these loops go back
and forth to classification
of information.
It really rules the
world, right? Even now.
- And knowledge becomes so
important in our times, right?
Think about Wikipedia.
- Right.
- And how it acts like a knowledge base,
the idea of linking knowledge base.
If China did not make
that step and get itself
in a digital age, none of what
it is now would be possible
at all.
Yep.
(Priya speaking indistinctly)
- [Attendant 2] Hi,
thank you for this talk.
I was really fascinated
by the Lin Yutang's typewriter method
when you brought it up and then I went
through this process of thought.
I was like,
"Oh yeah, I know what that is.
Wait a minute. I don't
know how to type Chinese.
I don't know what that is."
'Cause I used that in Korean and Japanese,
but there's a different approach.
Of course, you type it
out phonetically first
and you don't have to like,
but you still use Chinese characters.
- Well now we use, right,
now we use basically alphabet letters.
- [Attendant 2] Yeah.
In Chinese, yeah. I've heard
about that in China anyway.
- But in China like, you
still see these keyboards
because think of it this way.
If you can break down Chinese
into what turns out to be two
to four components,
every character can be
broken down to either like,
they get from anywhere from
two to four components.
That means two to four
keystrokes to make a character.
There are a lot of English words
that are not just four letters, right?
So in some ways you
can type faster, right?
Typing Chinese faster
on alphabetic keyboard.
So it's this remarkable, you know,
outcome of being able to
harness alphabet technology
and make Chinese better, right?
So instead of just becoming
completely wholesale,
alphabetized, which China could have,
it could just go with the
romanization system we have now.
But it's precisely because of
the will, passion, devotion
of people that I talk about
that character writing lived on.
- [Attendant 2] Right,
I was wondering, though,
with Korean and Japanese,
I don't know how familiar
you are with like,
the history of this,
'cause they had their
own challenges of course
to making up mechanical
and then computerized
type writing differently
than writing in other languages.
But do you know if they like,
all just happened to converge
on that system where like,
'cause when I typed in Korean,
I type it up phonetically.
If I wanna make a hanja,
a Chinese character,
it will be a numbered list
and I can like, hit the number
and get the one I want to sort of turn
that phonetic character,
phonetic block into a Chinese character
and similar in Japanese.
Do you know if this is all
is like they were all looking
to China and this all linearly traces back
to Lin Yutang or it was
just convergent evolution
on like, what worked best, like
some more like miraculously?
- I'm glad you asked that
question because sometimes,
I get like, you know, grumbles
from Japan knowledges who say
I don't give enough to Japan
because Japan, of course, have
been using Chinese characters
as part of their three writing systems.
And in fact, early Japanese
typewriters were also used
as references.
But there's one critical difference,
which China will make this
argument again and again
throughout the 20th century.
Japan only has a relatively
small number of characters
that it uses.
China only uses characters.
So, you know, it's like
this classic, you know,
this classic saying.
We talk about China, size matters, right?
So can it scale up technology
in Japan for its own use?
Not quite.
It needed something more expedient,
more encompassing that's
also more affordable, right?
But I'm glad you brought that up
'cause there's definitely
a lot of, you know,
like, inter-regional quibbles
that I won't talk about now,
but they are as good as that challenger,
that young challenger I told you about.
- Where does the microphone go next?
- [Attendant 2] I don't think
I can throw it that far.
- You can throw it
towards an intermediary.
- [Attendant 3] How's it going? There?
There you go.
- [Attendant 4] Thank you.
I was really interested
when you mentioned the like,
neuroscientific differences
between phonetic languages
or not, like, alphabet
languages and geographic ones.
And I was wondering with pinging
and like more phoneticization
when you do like character
input and typing,
does that change the
way people learn Chinese
and the way it's like,
represented in the mind?
- That's a very good question.
I would have to refer
you to the neuroscientist
to whom may pursue this at greater depth.
I mean, but what you point
out is something very valid is
that we interact with writing
a language differently now.
I think we're very close to
bypassing keyboard, right?
Because it's so much about voice input,
activation and AI technology
is really gonna change a lot
of that.
So, you know, one might also ask whether,
you know, this entire century, right,
or actually 400 years,
of modernizing Chinese
to the alphabetic infrastructure,
it brought us to a point where possibly,
their efforts are now
completely, you know,
absorbed into that progress, right?
- [Attendant 5] Hi, I
had a related question
about neuroscience and I wondered
if there's been any
studies about brain use
with a character language
versus a letter language
because it makes me think, you know,
people are always being told
do crossword puzzles or,
you know, all kinds of
puzzles to stretch your brain.
And I'm thinking,
someone who learns 5,000
patterns essentially
that they can recognize versus
someone who has 26 things,
it just seems like their
character brain would be stretched
from the outset,
and I just wonder if there
was any brain science on that.
- There's a couple of
people that you should read
and I had the pleasure
of consulting them both.
One is Mark Changizi.
You can find his book, I
think, "Vision Revolution."
Both came out in 2010.
The other one is (indistinct)
who's based in Paris.
But I just have a
personal anecdote to that.
So when I read Chinese,
I can read it very,
very quickly and a lot of times,
I don't read character
by character at all.
I can actually scan a page
and kinda tell what the
content is just because
that visual patterning has
become so familiar to me.
When I read English, I
can't read it the same way.
I can read it fast,
but it's still kinda like,
you know, scanning fast.
I can't just kind of as a, so
you say, just kind of like,
I can't just shine.
I can just shoot a glance at it
as though I'm just shining
a spotlight down the page
and get like a gist of
approximately what's the content.
Yeah.
- [Priya] So I think
there was somebody there?
- [Attendant 6] Yeah. I can talk loud.
- [Priya] No, no, no.
Microphone is coming.
- [Attendant 6] Thank you so much.
Thank you for the
wonderful, inspiring talk.
I wanted to know what the
emergence of this technology did
to the art of handwriting,
whether as an art form or on daily basis
to various generations.
I assume as it was the
case in the Middle East,
that was a very pressured
and beautiful art form
and we can see it in our family histories,
how our writing kind of degenerated
from one generation to another.
- I'm so glad you asked that
because it's very common,
with every technological
innovation, there's a lament,
a nostalgia for something
that's gonna be lost.
And it's clear that certainly,
I know my handwriting has
deteriorated at this age,
and I think that's a very
general lament as echoed
to educators around the world,
but I think the digital era has, also,
brought us something more, right?
So I do think it is true that
some art will be lost just
as when we look back,
there are many customs and
practice and art forms associated
with writing that we don't even use.
Even like poetry, Chinese
Literati used to write verse
whenever they see a friend,
when they have drinks together,
they can just dash up a verse like that.
For us, it'll be something
you probably have to work at
for two months, if not longer, right?
So I do think those habits,
technology does change,
I think, what we consider to be art,
but I think it's also
challenging, more importantly,
what innovation means and
what creativity means, right?
I'm personally very interested
in the idea of, you know,
this new literacy provided by the Googles
and the Wikipedias.
Like, what does it come down to
for knowledge is kinda gradually
replaced by information?
And that there's not a place
for wisdom and experience
because everything as in
wiki in the Wikipedia,
it means quick in Hawaiian
which is where it's from,
like as in the wiki wiki bus
if you've ever been to
Hawaii and take that bus
from the airport.
So, you know, we have a
completely different relationship
to what it means to know.
It's about, what's on my fingertips,
what's the first to search, you know,
the first three things that
might come up when I search
for something.
And I think that's actually
terribly frightening
'cause I certainly know that as a scholar,
as a humanist scholar,
my greatest inspiration is to
wonder through stacks and find
that accidental book that's
kind of someone misshelved
and kinda takes me on a different kind
of associational process thinking process.
But now that associational
process has been done for you
and they try to generate
randomness into it,
but that randomness where it's
almost like we're not working
for it.
We're just like typing it in,
letting the algorithm do it.
So I do think it's a kind
of strange leveling process
and frankly, as a teacher, I don't know
if Priya feels the same,
I don't know what it means
for future generation.
- [Priya] (indistinct)
For individual creativity.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Priya] It's the role
of the individual mind
because you're all mining
the collective mind
at this point, right?
But I had a quick question, if I may.
You know, so how did this impact,
so the artistic tradition of calligraphy,
was that really considered
as sort of high culture
and sort of a separate question,
sort of insulated from all
this sort of experimentation
with characters?
- Well, it's interesting you
say that because it also has
to do with how do you
preserve calligraphy,
which is so highly stylized
and individualized, right?
It's almost like your signatures,
so like your fingerprint.
And how that would enter
the digital age means how
to represent it in font, right, in fonts.
Now, when we talk about
fonts, you know, helvetica,
you know, garamond,
these ones that you see.
I use Calibri, I think.
But you won't believe this.
I mean, you might now that
you've heard this talk,
but in China, font design is huge
and they have managed to design these,
you know, really funky fonts all over.
So much so that last year,
I believe it was last year
or the year before, the
government issued a restriction,
admonishing people because as, you know,
these are just done by like,
you know, moving vectors,
you know, dragging this
and that using software.
It's not done through real
practice of calligraphy, right?
People are just randomly
fattening up this character
in a different like, as it was done like,
a particular handwriting,
but it's all just computer generated.
So there's actually kind
of just as, you know,
China's a hyper, I think,
technology friendly country.
But at the same time,
remember, it can do both
and it can understand the good
of modernization,
Westernization, technology,
but it also recognizes that
how it got itself this far was
to preserve its cultural
identity and its cultural core.
- And in many ways,
China was, one can say,
much more successful
than places like India
where we have a multitude
of languages but, you know,
colonialism really
pushed things out a bit.
It has had its advantages
in terms of, you know,
Indians learning how to speak English
and joining the Western
world much more seamlessly,
but it's interesting
that the British colonial
infrastructure did not get rid
of sort of this imposition of
the alphabet and the language.
Didn't have as much of a success.
- You know, China watched very closely.
- Yeah.
- It'd always cite what was
happening in India, Persia,
country civilization
that lost their language
when they became colonized.
So you have to understand
that this is still, you know,
what you hear now in the
headlines, like when China accuses,
you know, Charles Wesley
imperialism, American pluralism,
it's not just rhetoric, right?
It has basically ingrained
this way of thinking
that this is the one thing, right,
that it must guard itself
against and it goes back.
It goes way back. It's not
just the past 60 years.
- We have time for maybe one more question
if anybody wants to ask.
- [Attendant 7] Hi, professor.
I have a rather technical question
about Lin Yutang's typewriter.
So you mentioned that you have
to press two keys together
for the two parts,
but there's a lot of characters
that don't have two parts.
They're just one piece.
And so, how do you do with that?
- So what he recognized, and
thank you for that question,
is that it's not so much
you divide into two parts.
You need to just identify the top contour
and the bottom contour.
So it's kinda like the four corner system
where you kinda identify shape.
It's shape based.
So it's not necessarily true
that you can only share similar parts
because that will still be
a very unmanageable number.
But for instance, if your
top part is a stroke across,
many characters have that
as a starting stroke, right?
And same with the bottom
stroke, what sort of starts it?
So he actually makes it more elemental
than just looking at
in terms of components.
- [Attendant 7] I see. Then, okay.
I guess, why use top and bottom
instead of left and right?
- Sorry?
- [Attendant 7] Why top and bottom
instead of left and right?
- Statistically, that's
how he figured it out,
that it's actually not what
we think of as in, you know,
like two parts side by side,
which accounts for like,
top and bottom and side
by side counts for the
majority shape pattern
of Chinese character
writing but he figured out
that the top bottom is the
easiest for his purposes.
- [Attendant 7] That's interesting.
- Which is all the more extraordinary,
like how he arrived at this, right?
- [Attendant 8] First mover.
- Sorry?
- [Attendant 8] He was the first mover.
- He was the first mover,
but then, you know,
there've been so many others.
It's really a collective
effort, it feels like.
People are indebted to him,
but they have also gone beyond him.
But nonetheless, yeah,
that was the opening salvo.
- [Priya] Great.
At this point, let's thank Jing
Tsu for this fantastic talk.
- Thank you for having me.
(audience clapping)
(gentle jingle)